The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: So this is
about evaluating microcredit.
And how to do it.
It's also a methods
lecture in some sense,
because it's going to
be an application where
it was done both as
reduced form, IV, as well
as structural.
So that gives us this
great opportunity
to think about pros and cons,
pluses and minuses, kind
of what you can get from
one and not from the other.
And this is about a
financial intervention.
So we have been consistent
in every single lecture
in talking about
financial constraints
and financial modeling and
talking about policy and policy
implications of changing
the financial system.
So this is an illustrative
to application
of that general theme.
Very little review
of the literature,
but there are two, three
applications-- actually
the truth is there is very few
RCT evaluations of microcredit.
Abhijit, Esther,
Cynthia, and Rachel
did one in Hyderabad, Spandana.
And in many ways,
the results are
strikingly similar
to what we're going
to find in the Thai villages
and even some similarity
to Morocco.
What I want to emphasize,
and they do too,
is the heterogeneity.
So, for example, in
Hyderabad, there's
group-based lending,
joint liability.
They're small loans,
female borrowers,
subsidized low rates.
On average, to be
put in italics,
there's no impact on
total expenditures.
But on average an increase
in durables in the short run.
And you might stop there,
and that would be a mistake,
because the really
interesting stuff
gets going when you start
looking at the people who
are running or might run
businesses, business creation,
business assets, self-employed
hours and profits increase
for those who already
had existing businesses.
Their durable
consumption goes up.
Non-durable does not.
Now, the consumption part
is similar to the aggregate.
But if you look,
at say, the those
who have as in a probit,
a high propensity
to start new businesses
in the sample,
they increase their
durable goods spending.
But they decrease their
non-durable goods spending.
So you are seeing something
constant on the average
and going down for one group.
And in fact, if you look at
the flip side, which is not
surprising given the
average is what it is,
the low propensity
business owners
actually increase their
consumption of non-durables.
So various heterogeneous
impact based, by the way,
on observables, namely
current business owners,
and unobservables
that are backed out
through these propensity
scores, as in probits.
So it's unobservable as well
as observable heterogeneity
that seems to matter.
Morocco similar, larger
loans, lending to men.
No effects on consumption.
Maybe some small reduction in
consumption for those doing
agriculture and livestock.
No effect on business creation,
but within existing businesses,
certain activities were
discontinued less often,
and the scale of
other activities,
as in agriculture and
livestock, increase.
So again, another aspect,
one, the consumption aspect
is kind of similar in the sense
that maybe for these guys that
seem to have some
business impact,
consumption might be
going down instead
of on average staying constant.
And then you have this kind of
nebulous effect on businesses.
A lot of people
think of microcredit
traditionally as an impetus
to business creation.
It's to allow talented,
if poor, people
to enter and expand and
also enter into business.
And, in fact, some of the early
micro founded macro models
that we went through in
class very much feature
that vehicle--
people going into business
who couldn't previously,
as their wealth expanded, you
know, driving aggregate TFP.
Now, that's not to say
those studies were wrong.
These things can vary
across countries.
And they can vary
within a given country,
according to kind of the
state of the financial system.
And the overall
development path.
But we'll see, again, in
the Thai study, this a bit
of a struggle to
figure out what's
going on within existing
businesses that's allowing them
to be more profitable.
And that durable goods
things, you know, again,
as we've studied in
the financial accounts,
we make decisions
about classification.
But some durable goods are
used not just as a service flow
for household consumption,
but also potentially
used in the business.
And if there are sort
of increase in durables
might suggest, they're
actually expanding
the business in some way,
not just taking it out
in terms of increased
consumption.
So in Thailand, it's
the Million Baht Fund.
It was a government
intervention.
It was not a randomized
control trial.
And I guess I'll deal
with that right away.
How are we doing an
evaluation as if it were
a randomized control trial?
Well, it was basically a
million baht per village.
Villages are well-defined
geopolitical entities.
But they vary in terms
of total population size.
So all villages got the
same amount of credit.
The villages with
fewer households
got a higher per
capita treatment.
And there were 72,000 villages,
by the way, in Thailand.
And they all got something in
the order of $24,000, $25,000.
So this was approximately
1.5% percent of GDP.
So you could easily claim it's
the world's largest microcredit
sort of expansion
and evaluation.
Now, it's a
quasi-experimental design.
You'll see in the slides,
but I'll say it now,
you know, we carefully look
at pre-intervention trends
to see whether there's anything
else going on systematically
in a comparison between
small and large villages.
And we can't find much.
We've even gotten the maps
out and used this community
development department data for
all the villages in Thailand
and looked at village size to
see if, for example, larger
villages are near urban areas or
nearer to main roads and so on.
They're not.
We only find one or two
variables that are correlated.
And you kind of expect
if you're searching
over hundreds of variables to
find a few things now and then.
So we're going to look
at the effect of credit
on consumption,
investment, income.
And we're also going to look
at some general equilibrium
effects.
And again, just for worry that
I'll forget to say it later,
if you view villages as
small open economies--
and we have seen
papers on that--
then by intervening
village by village,
there's some sense in which
you're intervening country
by country.
That's pretty rare opportunity.
These models we've
been dealing with
take a stand on what might
happen with wages, for example,
in general equilibrium.
So we can actually see if
there's a wage effect going on
over and above the
potential benefits
or other impacts on
households who got credit.
Households who don't
even get credit,
but live in a village where
business might be expanding
would be villages given certain
obstacles to total migration,
would be villages where
the wages are going up.
And again, that's what we saw
in those first few lectures
to be the impact
of the expansion
of the financial system.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So I guess, ex
ante, did it surprise you
that there was no
correlation between things
like village size and proximity
to resources or productivity
of the average business
in the village or--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: One thing,
it's a political decision.
And they divide and
subdivide villages.
But they don't do it on a
regular, persistent basis.
So if a village were
getting bigger and bigger
for economic reasons,
then it could
get divided by the government
into two separate villages.
AUDIENCE: So what is the
measure that you looked down?
The one decided
by the government?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
At a moment in time,
we have the identity
of each of the villages.
And we count the number of
households in the village.
AUDIENCE: So
potentially something
that we count as two villages
is actually one big village?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Well,
so the real question
is whether the funds
could have leaked over
to neighboring villages.
The grant that established
this village-level institution
was for a village.
You know, like Downtown
Crossing gets a village fund.
Beacon Hill doesn't get one.
Sorry, close to home.
AUDIENCE: There's huge
incentive not share it, right?
I mean, it belongs
to your village.
Why would you want
someone else--
AUDIENCE: No, no,
what I mugging,
is I think sort of agricultural
or resource economics
suggests that
village size should
be endogenous to
resources in an area.
Like there should
be more villages
near freshwater source,
like in, you know,
maybe a thousand years
ago or something.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Well, but
then adjust for population.
Actually, I think your
argument goes the other way.
AUDIENCE: OK, sure, I mean--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: If villages
are an arbitrary collection
of people, then you might
want to have the same number
in each one of them.
There could be more villages.
But potentially there are same
number of people per village
if the government has
some systematic rule.
Now, the government is
messing around, but not as
systematically.
That's one comment.
The other thing is this leaking,
because if I could get credit
from some other village
and/or, as we've
seen with the informal
kinship networks,
get more money from
someone else who is
connected to another
village, then
we wouldn't have any power.
Now, we have looked at that too.
And again, we've done the GIS.
We've gotten all the
maps out and looked
at the impact on
villages nearby,
creating these sort of
smooth neighborhood averages.
And at least early on, the
impact doesn't spill over.
But that doesn't say in the
long run it might spill over,
which is another interesting
potential thing to do.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I have a
question that's similar--
how essentially villages
could be subdivided cities,
how you can consider
them small--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah,
have I answered it?
AUDIENCE: I think.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK.
AUDIENCE: Well, I still
don't get why you can,
but if empirically it looks
like there aren't spillover.
I guess that's somewhat
of a justification.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I accept
what you're saying is true.
But it confuses me from
like a priori point of view
why is that just--
it seams--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Well, we
didn't take it for granted
and get 3/4 of the
way through the study
and then think about it.
AUDIENCE: No, no, I know--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: We
looked right away,
and I would have thought--
AUDIENCE: I can tell from--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: My
hunch was larger villages
would be near the cities
and the main roads.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it might
have a higher average TFP
or something.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: There's
a map in the paper.
And, you know, I'd
created these slides kind
of too late to include it.
But you'll be
reassured by the map.
AUDIENCE: No, I believe you.
I am just confused by--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: You can
rub your hands on it and--
AUDIENCE: Some sort
of that's true.
But it's not true, like
you have some sort of hubs
all scattered around, so
like the size, you know--
AUDIENCE: So the one thing is
that if it's really urbanized--
so there's a limit.
Once you reach a
certain population,
so this takes care of
some of the heterogeneity.
Once the population
reaches a certain size,
like the government will just
designate it a town instead,
so it won't be a village.
AUDIENCE: Sure, that would
take care of some of it.
But it shouldn't take
care of all of it.
There should still be some
variation in the boundary.
Well, one would there
would be variation.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: It
would be depend on
how quickly they subdivide
them and so on and so forth.
AUDIENCE: That's true.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: We just looked
empirically and got reassured.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: A related question is
sort of who has the incentives
to subdivide up a village?
Like have there been other
sort of village-level programs
in the past which--
I'm not sure would
got the incentive.
But if predicted something
like Million Baht Village
was coming, you'd want to
subdivide your village.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Yeah, so on that,
the program was announced
pretty suddenly and implemented.
Thaksin ran on this and
implemented it very quickly
after being elected.
So arguably it couldn't
have been anticipated.
Now, you know, the
larger question is,
why was if he was
trying to maximize
votes you'd want it per capita?
Why give a lot of money
to a village where
there aren't very many people?
But, again, in the
Thai system, villages
are thought of as part of the
political system it's village,
tambon, amphoe, and so on.
So you give it to a
committee within the village
to run a fund.
And somehow it
seemed, quote, "fair."
It's great for us, right?
I mean, there's wonderful
mistakes in some respect.
It's kind of a
unique opportunity.
So we did that.
Oops, I see.
OK.
So as I said, it's
part of the GDP.
AUDIENCE: What is the 77,000?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah,
I think that's supposed
to be villages, not households.
That's too low.
This I've said.
So if you don't mine,
I'll just skip it.
Loans are about
$500, short-term,
as in one year,
typically two guarantors.
The interest rate was higher
initially at about 7%,
although the village committees
vote on those things.
And they allowed loans for both
consumption and investment,
unlike the stereotypical
program where
somehow consumption smoothing
is supposed to be a bad thing.
So it's my data.
But in this context,
probably bears
repeating because it's
unusual that we didn't
see this program coming either.
We're out there gathering
data year after year.
And we have five years of
the pre-intervention data.
We're going to exploit that
like crazy, because we're
going to write down a model,
which I'll tell you about,
and estimate it, all based
on the pre-intervention data,
and then simulate
the model in compared
to what actually happened.
We actually have six years
of post-program data too,
which is, again, rare, and
here, quite interesting.
Again, if you're thinking
about, which you may not,
but you might be thinking about
budget constraints to do RCTs
and so on.
It's quite expensive.
And gathering the data is
a big part of the expense.
So running a survey for a long
time before the intervention
and running it for a
long time afterwards
is almost prohibitively
expensive.
Or at least you wouldn't be able
to evaluate very many things.
But we didn't design
the data gathering
with this thing in mind.
It just happened.
I guess in that sense,
again, we just got lucky.
We're going to look at
four kinds of outcomes,
short-term credit,
overall, I might add,
not just from the village
funds, including, therefore,
borrowing from the BAC, the
Ag Bank, commercial banks,
the reasons for borrowing--
although I don't have
those slides for you
here because money's
potentially fungible.
We do look at interest
rates default and so on.
We have consumption broken
down in these annual data,
by the way, into
these categories.
Why these categories?
Well, we had the
socioeconomic survey.
And we did analysis when
we designed my survey
to see what subset
of consumption items
would best predict the total
in the socioeconomic survey.
So that's kind of in the spirit
of Blundell and Pistaferri
and so on in terms of taking
advantage, projecting to get
something bigger than food.
But actually there's some
interesting stuff with alcohol.
I'll show you, if
I remember, when
we get through these things.
Income and production decisions
is another class of categories.
We have assets and
income growth, even
in the annual data, divided
into business, wage and salary,
and agriculture and so on.
And we see revenues
and expenses.
And again, we have
some ability to look
at female headed as opposed
to male headed households.
OK, what's an outcome?
y for household n at date t.
This is like imagine running,
oh, my god, a simple-minded OLS
regression, the way people
sometimes used to do.
So Village Fund credit would
include the Million Baht Fund.
You want to see the impact
causally on an outcome.
Of course, we're going
to instrument this.
But the other things are these
household characteristics,
of various kinds, mainly
demographics, age, education,
number of kids, blah,
blah, blah, gender.
And then we have a time fixed
effects and a household fixed
effects, which are
estimated in the data.
And here's the endogenous
variable being instrumented.
And this is pretty simple.
And we also have those x
covariates here and time
and household fixed effects for
household short-term credit,
household and at date t.
But we've also got
some dummies that
kick in the first
year and second year
of the intervention.
Those are chis not x's.
Those are 0, 1 variables.
And they're interacted with the
inverse number of households.
So inverse, that's just
to get the sign right.
Although it's a parabola, so
it's not exactly not mattering.
But if you wanted this
thing to be positive,
the larger the
number of households,
the smaller this number,
and kind of the less
you would expect
the impact to be.
And then we have the usual all
the errors are uncorrelated
with each other, et
cetera, et cetera.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: How many
villages was this?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: This is 64,
because it's my annual data.
AUDIENCE: And can you also look
at outcomes in the CDD data?
You know, 450,000?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: We have
not amazingly done that.
AUDIENCE: CDD is at
the village level.
This a regression at
the household level.
AUDIENCE: That's true.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: But
you could potentially
do things across villages to
see where the villages got
more or less credit.
So the spirit of it is possible.
Someone actually looked at
the socioeconomic survey
and had enough connections
to the Nash NSO
to get it by village.
But their timing was off,
because their first year is
the year of the intervention.
And we have the
pre-intervention data.
But anyway, it's possible.
No one has looked at that.
AUDIENCE: What was year
of the intervention?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: The first year?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: 2002.
AUDIENCE: Why don't
they have the ISS data?
They just don't have the years?
I thought the ISS
go back 30 years.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: They
don't have a panel.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
But they don't have
panel afterward?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: They do.
They did.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But we don't have it.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: We
discovered it after.
We have it.
So we're going to look at new
short-term credit, consumption,
asset growth, and income.
Tried to do it pretty carefully.
We actually did it about
four more ways than this.
But reduced the number
of that we show.
OLS with all the problems
that you know about.
Here's an IV regression with all
villages as opposed to fifth--
this is kind of
outliers in village.
If you think about
that parabola,
you know, it's kind of getting
really steep when household
size is really small--
number of households is
small and not moving much.
So we clipped off,
took the big chunk,
but we clipped off the tails
of small and large villages
and dropped some outliers
from the household data too.
But every single way we do it,
short-term village fund credit
goes new, new, short-term
village credit goes up.
These are roughly the order of
magnitude of $25,000 divided
by the number of households.
So, you know, credit goes up.
You might be worried.
And like Esther and Abhijit
have papers where there's
this substitution going on.
You get cheap credit
from one source.
You borrow less
from other sources.
That doesn't happen.
In fact, arguably there seems to
be almost an amplifier effect,
but more weakly.
Short-term credit goes
up, for sure, one to one.
And you can see it in the data.
I mean, this is this like a huge
spike in the financial system.
And it didn't go down.
That part doesn't go
down subsequently.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: If we thought
that going up variable
was-- took that seriously, could
that be something like people
getting extra funds
and re-lending
and so you have to
sort of multiplier?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: It's true one.
Would have to--
that's a good point.
Once could be just--
not to say that
it's a bad thing.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
But, you know, you
have these sort of combinations
of characteristics of loans.
And if the village
fund committee
has this cap, which
they're supposed
to have on the
loan size, then you
get one leg up and think
about doing something.
Maybe you want to go the
money lender or other sources
and lever up even more
when you have chunkiness.
AUDIENCE: So this is
because it's going
more one to one, the credit?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
But the more conservative way
to read it is just one for one
anyway.
So it's not like a substitute
for other sources of money.
AUDIENCE: So when
I initially looked
at it I thought this support
for Esther and Abhijit's idea
that if you can get
over a hump, then
you'll really want to
expand or something.
But I think what you
were saying is could they
be re-lending to each other?
So I could I be--
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Yeah, he did say that.
And, yeah, that
could be going on.
AUDIENCE: OK.
That's a convenient explanation.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
And I don't think
we tried to take that out.
We're just looking
at the household
and at date t in some
village j and adding up
all the short-term
loans that they have.
So if you only counted the
loan and not the lending,
if it wasn't net, and
I think it wasn't.
I think it's just gross.
AUDIENCE: Not all
loans are one year.
They're are loans
that are one week.
AUDIENCE: No, sure, yeah.
AUDIENCE: They almost have
different lending, really,
really short term.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: So that's
why we did short term instead
of long term.
Consumption levels,
other than the OLS--
I'll come back to that-- go up.
Significantly, asset growth in
one specification goes down.
Now, I can't help it
but say that we're going
to have to choose a model.
What I'm going to do now--
I'm giving you these
stylized facts--
but what model comes to your
head on why things like savings
might go down?
Like a buffer stock model.
If you're on your
own, you're saving
for these future disasters.
Now, in the future,
you could borrow
if you believe the village
fund is persistent.
So you don't need to have
so many buffer stocks.
So net financial savings
goes down actually.
And we have trouble finding
stuff with the capital stock.
I'll mention that.
By the way, these
consumption magnitudes
are very similar to
the credit magnitudes.
So a bit naively,
you might say they
used it all for consumption.
Now, again, what
model do we have
that would predict
that consumption
ought to go up one for one
with an increase in credit?
AUDIENCE: Life time
permanent income model.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: What
would the permanent income
model give you?
AUDIENCE: It would
go up, wouldn't it?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: How much?
AUDIENCE: It has hazard shock
is temporary or persistent.
AUDIENCE: You would think
this persistent, right?
So then it should
jump to the new--
but I don't know how much.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: You'd
put it in the bank
basically and draw the
interest off of it.
AUDIENCE: This is a
temporary shock, right?
It's just once.
AUDIENCE: Then you
can get the funds back
and you lend it again.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Either way.
AUDIENCE: We're missing it.
What's the--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: No, no,
no, I'm just saying--
no, no, you got close.
I mean, the point is the
permanent income model
isn't going to get you this.
And you've got to have
these credit constraints.
You've got to be something
that's generating hand
to mouth like behavior.
AUDIENCE: So this is a shock
to the credit constraint not
the shock to income.
So you should be facing
this credit constraint--
you should be constrained.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Yeah, that's right.
And therefore, you're going to
see that this overall average
is masking a very
big differential
impact in the population
depending on whether someone's
at that constraint or not.
AUDIENCE: But even
if you are not
constrained, if you
anticipate that in the future
I'm constrained,
endogenously you--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: It depends
on the interpretation.
Suppose you thought,
you know, the government
gave the money lump
sum to the households
indirectly through
the village fund.
And they just put
that in the bank.
Then their net
worth has gone up.
They don't have an obligation.
Within the village, they
are borrowing and lending
against this fund.
But the village, as a whole,
just got a whole lot richer.
And they would
potentially, if you
believed in the
permanent income,
raise their asset level, right?
And then get the flow off of it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How is it financed?
Is it something like--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Taxes.
AUDIENCE: But like the
taxes mainly hitting
cities instead of villages?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I see.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Matt.
AUDIENCE: So I
was a bit confused
between the OLS and
the IV, because what
is the expansion
variable in OLS I
was thinking it must
be credit per person.
But then I don't
understand really
what the instrument is, right?
Because if its credit per
person it's just a million
divided by number of households.
And that instrument
itself is per household.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
So there's a lot
of variation in
short-term village credit,
both among households within
a village and across villages.
So we're identifying
this through
the cross-sectional variation.
We're saying what part of the
increase in observed increase
in short-term village credit
can be explained simply
by inverse population size?
And the OLS doesn't do that?
It's just a flat out regression
credit on the right-hand side
and impacts on the left.
All credit.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: And, you know,
net income growth is positive
in 3 to the 4,
including the OLS,
or 2 of the 3 if you don't.
And so there is some
impact on overall growth,
not levels, growth.
And this is by source of income.
You know, we see
a hint of profits,
apropos the first two three
slides of the lecture today.
Profits may be going up.
And wages and salary
payments are going up
pretty consistently.
So again, you know,
what that's all about?
But I've already
given some of it away.
The wage rate that's
going up for villages
that got a higher
per capita treatment.
And potentially
employment goes up.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: So this slide and
the previous slide as well.
I mean I understand we're
talking about bahts,
so the quantities are big.
But like some of yours are huge.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: But
you can see the stars.
AUDIENCE: No, no, no,
I understand that.
But even in the previous
slides, on stuff
that's like the growth rates,
the standard errors are big.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You don't get clear
zeros and stuff like that.
So--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Wait, I'm
not sure what you're saying.
Yes, the standard
errors can be big.
That would make it tough to
identify significant effects.
But we on occasion do
find significant effects.
AUDIENCE: No, I understand that.
I'm just wondering-- my question
was more of as technical one.
Like how-- is there a way to
sort of make them smaller.
I mean I guess it's an issue
of ID and stuff like that.
But--
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Well, you know, this
is with clustered standard
errors and the whole thing.
And we try to eliminate the
outliers to see if that's kind
of causing a lot of the noise.
Sometimes it does.
It doesn't do that consistently.
OK.
We don't find much with
ag or other sources
of income or livestock.
Now, as I said,
we also have a lot
of post data, post-intervention.
Even when we wrote this thing,
we're up to six years of data.
But this is OLS.
So you have to take it with a
bit more of the grain of salt.
For example, consumption
isn't showing up,
even initially because we're
not instrumenting anymore.
The probability of default's
kind of moving around.
And it doesn't go away.
And that's a real issue.
And let me show you
the default rates.
And, you know, potentially, by
the way, there should be a lag.
Depending on exactly
where the 12 month falls,
you borrow one year and
you can't repay the next.
Net income goes up.
But it's not
significant after that.
And short-term village
credit remains high.
Well, what do I want to say?
Back to models, you'll
get one, don't worry.
You know, the
world isn't static.
And we just shook
things a little bit,
because these villages
arguably are wealthier
than they were and they've
also somehow used this
to capitalize basically a
savings and loan association
within each of the village.
So if you were in
a steady state,
and someone smacked you in
the head with something good,
you might expect the adjustment
isn't necessarily insta--
all the dynamic models we
have with frictions, Paco's,
for example, suggests there
are slow transitions even
to some ultimate
new steady state.
So this is rare, this look
at these-- now, granted,
the model's going to be partial
equilibrium, even though we
have some data on local wages.
And there's a guy named--
is it Furfine who has a study?
Pandi and Burgess had
this study in India
where the government
changed the branching rules
and showed impacts on poverty
and all of that stuff.
But he went back after
they published their paper
and looked at the
long-term impact.
And he thinks something like
this was going on in India too.
So again, apropos, you
know, RCTs, well, no one
claimed the contrary,
but if you don't
know what happens
afterwards, you're
kind of left with the
impression and hope
that the program effects, if
they were positive, persisted.
Here, they're definitely
mitigating over time.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you have the
long-term impact on wages?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: I don't
think we looked at that.
That would be good to do.
We struggle with the wage,
because the annual data
measure it very well.
So this is the one thing that
we use the monthly data for.
And we only have 16 villages.
So it's quite problematic.
Most things we try don't
show up because of the sample
size is too low and the
standard errors just kill us.
But I don't think we actually
looked at long-term wages.
So that would be good to do.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you think the
wage data in CDD is any good?
Daily wage for laborers.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: I
think when you sort of
look at geographic averages
of things, yeah, that it has--
there are beautiful maps
showing how wages, not size,
but wages move as you
get near urban areas
and get near Bangkok.
And so arguably, something
could potentially--
I wouldn't trust any
one head man's response,
but with 72,000 data
points, you can do a lot.
AUDIENCE: So that paper,
his name is Fulford.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Fulford.
OK, so this is a
cautionary tale.
I'm going to skip it.
If we have time,
I'll do it next time.
That would be a
better context for it.
So I've been trying to clue
you into the puzzles all along
in terms of--
the one thing I didn't
say was about investment.
And I had mentioned
in other lectures
that investment doesn't
happen very often.
And when it happens, it's big.
So it's quite lumpy.
And we're going to want
to incorporate that.
But the flip side
of that is we're
going to have trouble
finding effects of investment
both in the IV and in
the structural model,
and the data generated
from the structural model,
if we limit that data
to the same sample
size that we have in reality.
But when you see the
structural model momentarily,
you can imagine a 10-fold
increase in the sample size
because we can generate
as much data as we want.
And then, we definitely get
these investment effects.
So, you know,
arguably one reason
still on the table that we
don't see microcredit directly
in terms of
investment activities
is simply a sample size issue.
I mentioned that
because, you know,
people write reviews
of what do we
know about microcredit
and whether or not it
having an impact.
And there seems to be
a bit of a consensus
that at best, impact
is quite mixed.
And maybe, you know,
non-existent in many studies.
And people come away with
this impression that, at most,
it's all about consumption.
But I think that's a little
bit of a rush to judgment.
I'm not saying it
has to be this too.
I don't have more data
in reality than we have.
So we're going to have
this precautionary savings.
We're going to have some limits
because of those consumption
numbers I showed you.
We're going to allow default.
It does happen in reality.
And we're going to try to
match the default rate.
And we have income growth.
That's actually arguably the
hardest thing that we did.
And I'll try to say something
about why it was hard.
But we actually allow
persistent growth in the model.
OK, so what is the model?
Liquid stuff is just your
current income plus your return
on previous year savings.
Now, this reminds
me to say, you know,
so why aren't you doing
moral hazard or costly state
verification or
full information?
Hey, we just had a
lecture about that.
Same kind of data.
Alex and I showed that
in the rural data,
the best approximation is
something simple like savings
only or limited borrowing.
Now, we got lucky,
because Alex and I
did that after Joe and
I wrote this paper.
But it is at least
very comforting
that the best micro
underpinning that we now think
exists out there was the
micro underpinning that
was being used in this paper.
Likewise, I would not
expect to get the same thing
in the urban areas,
because there, Alex and I
found moral hazard was
a better approximation.
So here, it's sort of this
incomplete market's macro type
literature or development
literature, for that matter.
Rotsio swears by this stuff.
And it's in logs.
So income looks like it's
just a multiplicative
transitory and permanent shock.
That makes the log of
income equal to the log
of some permanent thing and the
log is some transitory thing.
The log of the
permanent thing almost
looks like a random
walk, where log Pt plus 1
equals log Pt plus
log N. So this is
the shock to permanent income.
This thing is the shock to
transitory income, where
income is measured in logs.
Now, it's not quite
that because G
is this drift, this damn drift.
It's 4%, by the way.
So you know, there's kind of
sustained growth, not modeled.
You get this boost to
your permanent income.
It's like TFP type stuff.
And then what's this?
So investment, you
know, why invest
if it doesn't do anything?
Well, on the
contrary, investment
gives you a boost of your
permanent income, right?
So this is this decision whether
or not to invest, a dummy.
And this is the amount
of the investment.
As I said, investment
opportunities
arrive stochastically
from a distribution
with a non-trivial mean.
So on average,
it's chunky, which
means you may choose not
to do it because it's
too big to swallow.
You don't get a choice
about the size though.
If you do it, you've got
to do the size that arrived
to you as an approximation.
Although again, I've said
this, we see this in the data.
People don't do sort
of half chicken coops.
A chicken coop without
a roof is not a coop.
OK.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the drift term.
I think we have in
papers we have--
we basically assume some
exogenous technical progress
pushing wages up
and then like papers
where the focus on
the structural model
is to model that,
because obviously
like that's really important
if Thailand over this period
there was 4% drift where
everyone or maybe--
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
It is important.
And we're not.
A lot of the literature
we've covered doesn't.
Daron features that a lot.
What is it?
Is it innovation?
What is this
technological progress?
AUDIENCE: So would it be--
Are there any
inherent reasons why
it would be difficult to
translate Daron's models
to the Thai data or the--
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
It should be done--
AUDIENCE: With
regional variation?
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
It should be done.
It hasn't been done yet.
No, I don't see any
intrinsic difficulty.
Actually, it's more
like a real opportunity,
because when you're on
the ground like this,
you should be able to see--
and in my data, you measure the
capital stock and labor input
and all of--
you know, if it's real
technological improvement it's
like, mm, getting rid
of the water buffalo,
and bringing in the
walking tractor.
I showed you a picture
of the walking tractor.
I said it was land,
labor, and capital.
Remember that one?
Well, it used to
be water buffalo
and the people in
Bangkok still think
that you know the farmers are
out there with their water
buffalo.
Well, I mean, it's
just not true.
You know, they have pickup
trucks and all of that.
So my point is that that's
real technological progress.
And so data like
this potentially
could tell you whether
it's really that or just
potentially something else.
It could be better roads, you
know, higher, easier access
to markets that
somehow showing up,
everything else equal,
but not modeled, and not
at a deep level.
OK.
So here's the max problem.
Maximize discounted expected
utility of this household.
Rho is sort of the
related to the coefficient
of relative risk aversion.
Beta is the discount rate.
This is as of, quote,
"initial period."
Here's the liquidity.
That, by the way, was
the same as interest
on savings, short-term liquid
savings plus current income.
And it can be spent on
consumption or saving
or investment.
If you decide, D, to do the size
investment that has arrived.
What are the state variables?
In any given day-- this
is true for every day, t.
It would have been better,
and I don't have it
on the slides, to show you a
traditional value function,
where you'd have the utility
today plus the value tomorrow.
But this does tell you what
the state variables are namely,
permanent income
today, liquidity today,
and the size of the
investment draw.
So those are the
key economic states.
That's households
are going to face.
This is just a parameter.
What is s bar?
Here it is.
Now, it looks like savings
is bounded from below,
weird, weird.
Well, actually savings
can go negative.
That's fine.
That's just borrowing.
So this is a credit limit.
It says savings can't
go too negative,
credit can't be too big.
And it's scale by
permanent income.
In fact, almost
everything in the model
is going to get scaled
by permanent income.
Part of that is the permanent
income, we wanted growth.
And the way to get
the growth is to have
this expansion exogenously
in permanent income.
But the other thing is
you look at the data,
and you see, you
know, like investments
are large for small households
relative to their assets.
And you go to larger households,
and their projects scale up.
So it's not like you can
sort of accumulate wealth
and save your way out of
these non-convexities.
So we scaled everything--
go to the other extreme--
we scale everything
by permanent income.
The arrival of project
sizes and so on and so forth
and the shocks are all scale.
And what I'm not writing
down, but we do in the paper,
is to actually turn this
into a balanced growth path.
And the intuition is
pretty much what I said.
The math is trickier,
where you just
divide through by p everywhere.
So the control
variables are things
like consumption per
permanent income,
per unit permanent income.
And then we have to solve
the value functions.
Now, these are the
stochastic processes
for the transitory shock.
Again, everything is in logs.
The permanent shock, so
these are log normal,
centered around zero with
these standard deviations.
Project side is not
centered around zero.
It has a non-trivial mean
with the standard deviation.
And you're going to see
a table with parameters--
not to say you're
really memorizing these.
I am, because I want
to go through the list
when we get there--
mu sigma, U, N.
Here's a problem.
We do have a borrowing limit.
And we do not put in sort
of a natural borrowing.
We let households default. They
default in the data, about 18%.
It's not trivial.
It's also hard to nail down
exactly when a loan is not
performing, because they can
stretch out the payments.
So it's not nailed
at exactly 18%.
And, oh, yeah, so here's
another story with a bonus.
Econometrica requires the
codes for any published paper.
So you've got to give them
the codes and the data,
which is good.
It's a good thing.
Of course, when
you're doing the work,
you don't really annotate as
thoroughly as you might do.
And then when you're ready
to publish this stuff,
you're going to like
go back over it,
and we found a mistake.
And the mistake was
around this default rate.
So we actually know,
for bad reasons,
that the default rate matters.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I saw two
versions of a paper
and they had quite
different welfare coverages.
Was that--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's
probably part of it, yeah.
Well, look, everyone makes
mistakes in research.
And it's in some respect
doing it over and over
is actually a good
thing, because you
get this robustness check.
But, yeah--
AUDIENCE: So in the data, when
we say a household defaults,
what do we mean exactly by that?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Never
paid off the loan.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Because in most
microcredit literature
a default is what we
would call a delinquency
in the sort of developed
country finance literatures.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you're not counting
deliquincies as default.
You're counting actual
defaults, like we just
never pay the money back.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: You know, I
have to go back and make sure.
We could have put something like
a two-year threshold on this.
But, yeah, I mean, I always
actually go the other way.
I tend to think of defaults
as a contingency in the loan
contract.
The Bank for
Agriculture for sure
runs an insurance company this
way, where they extend loans
and actually even more
than that don't charge you
interest on the renewed
principle and so on.
So, you know, people
are risk averse,
having these contingencies
are a good thing.
There is a literature on
this, other literatures.
So anyway, there may
be other ways to do it.
Measurement is tricky.
But we decided to
put default in.
And what is this thing saying?
Well, it's a bit tricky to read.
But we don't drive people
down to zero consumption.
We put in some
minimum consumption.
No matter what, you're not
going to go below c lower bar
and, well, scaled by
your permanent income
as everything else is.
Now, what is this other thing?
Savings.
Well, put savings times
p on the right-hand side.
It'll pick up a negative sign.
That's credit.
Minus savings is credit.
So it's liquidity
plus the maximum loan
you could take out.
And still, you can't cover
that minimum consumption.
So you're not respecting the
budget constraint anymore.
You get this, quote, "gift."
And then here are the rules that
happen and when you default.
You're not investing.
You're borrowing
up to the limit.
And your consumption
is the scaled version
of permanent income.
So let's see if I've done
my homework, or you have.
R is the interest rate.
This is the standard deviation
of the permanent shock,
standard deviation of
the transitory shock.
This is new.
It's measurement error.
We imagine that we see
the data contaminated.
It's a bit dirty
centered around the mean.
But this is the drift term.
This is the lower bound on
consumption under default.
Beta is the discount rate.
Rho is related to constant
relative risk aversion.
Mu is the project size.
On average, sigma i is
the standard deviation
of project size.
And this is the credit limit.
And R, big R, is the
return on investment
that augments permanent income.
That's also quite problematic.
What we did was use these
return on assets numbers.
But, Emily and Abhijit and I
have been working subsequently.
And we think not
only does R vary
in the population with
some heterogeneity
that we don't have
here, but it actually
is predictive of who's
getting the money
and what they're doing with
it, which may be another reason
that we didn't get as far
as we thought we might
with the investment thing.
But anyway hopefully, we'll
write that up real soon.
Here, it's just a number,
calibrated, you might say.
And we're going to
use method of moments.
Oh, now, a couple of questions
for you guys, or one comment.
Back to the codes,
you know, Emily
was about your cohort
in a class like this.
And very shortly thereafter,
she got interested
in the structural stuff.
The codes are all there.
And, you know, not only
the published version,
but all the other things,
you're welcome to have them.
Probably a little late
to do it for the class,
but it's a resource
that's available to you.
And, of course, in the end it
wasn't the paper with Abhijit
that's still not quite done.
But she used structural modeling
in her job market paper.
And she was learning it
by looking at those codes.
So the other thing
I want to ask you,
I hope you've seen at some point
methods of simulated moments.
One yes, three, four yes, OK.
So we're going to--
AUDIENCE: For those of us who
took Devop 771 in the Fall,
Esther had a problem
set on your papers.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Have you
learned have something
new today?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
Like we did the methods
of moments already.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK.
All right, that's excellent.
Yeah, that's excellent.
I guess I knew that.
I'd forgotten.
But anyone, I'm
glad you know it.
So I won't try to reteach.
There's not time today.
OK, another
controversy, what to do
with all the
heterogeneity in the data
that we don't have in the model?
I'm emphasizing certain aspects
of observed and unobserved
heterogeneity in the data.
That is in the model.
But we've also got all
these demographic stuff.
Now, granted not everyone
would do it this way.
We take it out.
So we filter the data basically.
We regress the household
data on these observables
and as well as time trends,
potential initial business
cycle, i.e.
the initial data is one year
after the financial crisis,
the whole country is kind of--
so the controversy is, well,
why don't you just put it in--
and I'm not going to
have time this year.
But I have lectured
in previous years
on Keane and Wolpin and stuff.
So if you want to see a really,
really long specification
of what you can put into
the utility function,
I'm not debunking it.
It's a perfect--
[AUDIO OUT]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: We
kind of estimate it.
But this is almost
like calibration,
because we have earned interest,
which is interest time savings.
And we have savings and
interest in the data.
So we are trying to minimize
to get the mean right.
The other things
that are more fun--
consumption, decision to invest,
and so on is just basically
looking at consumption
in the data.
And this is expected consumption
through the lens of the model.
It's conditioned on observables.
Liquidity is observed.
And income is observed.
Now, one caution, these are not
one to one with the key state
variables of the model itself.
There are something
like permanent income
and project size relative
to permanent income
are the key state variables.
And permanent income
is unobserved.
So there's some work to
back out these expectations.
But anyway, you
get an error, which
is the difference
between the observed
and the predicted values.
And you kind of like want
to minimize the error term
by choosing the
parameter values here.
Here's a la Blundell,
Pistaferri and Preston.
We put in a log moving
average process for income.
So if you're judicious about
choosing log differences far
enough apart, you can
pick up the drift.
It's really very similar
to what BPP we're doing.
And that's how we
get that G basically.
So these are time
differences in growth rates.
Maybe I don't need to--
and then, of course,
you can pick up other moments
by the orthogonality conditions
on error terms, assuming that
they don't see something else.
If they were to
see something else
we're not seeing
in the model, then
we're going to make a
mistake with these guys,
because there's going to
be information contained
in the error.
But we assume not.
Simulating, what
are we going to do?
Well, first of all, how do
we relax the borrowing limit?
We allow that borrowing
limit, that s bar,
to move from one village
to the next in such a way
as to predict the increase
in short-term village credit
that we see in the data.
So that's how we sort of
calibrate the magnitude
of the intervention.
And the rest is simulation.
We're going to draw these shocks
over and over again and get
repeated samples.
We're going to have basically
500 artificial data sets.
Any one data set is
a series of draws
of the permanent transitory
project size and so on.
And we have the
pre-intervention years.
You can stop there
and use the data
and estimate the parameters.
You can keep going and see
what the model predicts
over and over again,
not just one path,
but averaging over these
500 different paths.
Why do that?
Well, basically, you want
to get average tendencies.
You don't want to be so
sensitive to the luck
of the draw in the first
year after the intervention
and the second year
after the intervention,
because we don't know what--
the model says-- we know
something about averages.
In fact, then we run--
this slide really deteriorated
through the projector.
But these are the economic
variables in the model itself.
Liquidity divided
by permanent income,
projects size divided
by permanent income.
And what's going on here, as
you move in this direction,
there's three black dots here.
And they're kind of
all fixing project
size and varying liquidity.
So these guys down
here are bankrupt.
They're defaulting.
They have almost no liquidity.
They can't even really pay
back their previous loans.
These guys, these are
these hand-to-mouth guys.
This thing's really curvy.
They're constrained.
They're liquidity constrained.
That borrowing
constraint is binding.
These guys have drifted
into higher territory.
They're not actually
constrained anymore.
But in the future, they know
there are credit limits and so
on.
If you go this way,
you're basically
fixing liquidity and
varying project size.
Now, the most interesting
part of the diagram
is the Grand Canyon here.
And this sort of
pre-intervention,
this guy sitting close to the
cliff, he's tempted to invest.
But given limited
resources, investment
would drive his
consumption really low.
And he's not willing to do it.
But then you have this sort
of increment in the borrowing
resources.
It's like another [AUDIO OUT]
that effect on consumption,
we've got these four.
These guys don't move
consumption basically.
Oh, well, let me get at the
welfare stuff right now.
So for them, this credit
program is terrible.
Why?
Because we're not going to
force them into default anymore.
We're going to
make them take out
a loan at interest, whereas
before they got exempt
from repayment.
So welfare goes down
for these guys down here
as a result of the
village fund program.
Welfare goes up for these
credit constrained guys,
because they're at
the borrowing limit,
and that's precisely
what this new program
is doing, at least through
the lens of the model.
These guys, you'd say, well,
they're not constrained.
No, but they're these
buffer stock guys.
And they now have
excess liquidity.
Well, might as well
spend some of it.
So their consumption
also goes up.
And as I just said,
these guys who
drop off the cliff, so
to speak, they actually
have consumption drops.
So this consumption average
that we see, 1 to 1,
is this mongrel weighted average
of overall this heterogeneity,
of course, that we
only create sort of
through the eye of the model.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you
understand the guy
who's like constantly
bankrupt is worse off?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Because
before we would have forgiven
the loans, sent him to a minimum
consumption c bar and let
him start over.
And now, he's saddled with
all that previous debt.
And he can basically borrow more
against it at interest rates
and then have to pay
off in the future.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
Because we expanded his
ability to refinance,
now he's worse off.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, exactly.
AUDIENCE: That's different--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: If the
government exempts your loan
and you stay in the house.
But--
AUDIENCE: So if
would be different
if you were borrowing
from a money lending who
is going to break his knee.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, so
you could imagine default
doesn't work like this.
But that's the way it
works in the model.
Anyway, and then you know after
they climb out of the cliff,
you get a repeat in terms of--
so if you looked at
those welfare numbers,
it's almost misleading.
In fact, I thought it
was wrong for a minute.
This looks like it's just--
the bankruptcy region,
there are these huge gains.
No, the bankruptcy,
these guys are losing.
They're negative
numbers down here.
What happens is very
close, but not very
adjacent to that
bankruptcy reason,
the welfare gains just
you know rise like a tent.
It's actually not vertical.
It's just coming up real
fast and then coming down.
It's a very steep tent.
So these guys are
really in the program.
And then these other
constrained people,
they're kind of
liking the program.
All these people are
actually relative to what?
Well, basically,
we use the model
to look at an
alternative program,
where they just get
a lump sum transfer.
And we actually do this
consumption equivalent
calculation, which is
how much of a transfer
would you have to
get to have a welfare
gain equivalent to the one
you get under a Million Baht
Program.
And another way to say it, in
this region, the government
could have saved money.
It could have gotten households
the equivalent welfare gain
without actually putting so
much money in the village.
But it's very heterogeneous.
Some people are tempted, and
the abstract on the paper
actually talks about it
not being a great program.
But I don't know, strictly
speaking, Pareto criterion,
we can't say that.
24% of the population
really love this program.
For them, it's wonderful.
But more than the
majority would have
preferred a different program.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: So that
type of comparisons
is just looking in
people's welfare
in the model, not thinking
about cushion being administer,
for instance.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Oh, yeah,
we're extracting away
from the people who are
financing the programs.
So there's all those
tax distortions
being created to
generate the revenue
to fund this program that aren't
involved in this calculation.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I
was just thinking
organizational capacity.
So maybe one reason for
loaning to each village
is that by head count, there's
be a lot more variation--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Maybe--
AUDIENCE: Than a simple version.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
And then I just want
to say that we come back to
those IV regressions, two
comments.
First of all, what do
these coefficients mean?
Well, you can think about
them as impact of the program.
But that's kind of
like a funny number,
because it's an average over
all these different people who
got treated differently
and had different views
about the program.
So we're lucky in a way that
we saw this big salient number.
And it helped us figure out a
model where something like that
could happen.
But then with that
model, we realize
this number is not a uniform
benefit for all the households.
So in other words,
a big advantage
of a structural
model conditioned
on believing that you're getting
the structure somewhat right
is that it allows
you to really look
at the distribution of
welfare gains and losses.
The other comment
is more favorable.
Since we did those
IV regressions
and I reported
them, we can run--
we can generate--
we did generate--
the data from the model over
and over again, as I said,
and then do exactly the same
IV type regressions on the data
from the model and take--
so we're comparing
apples to apples.
It's kind of a funny
intermediate criterion,
but it is at least a
consistent criterion
that's used on the model
generated data as well
as the actual data.
And the fit is
actually pretty good.
So I think that's it.
Thank you.